when it comes to buying smartphones it's
been all about the Benjamins at least
six or seven of them the newest iPhones
and Galaxy phones tend to start at six
hundred and fifty dollars but what if
we've been buying too much phone like
hundreds of dollars too much this is the
blue r1 HD
yes a $50 Android smartphone you want to
know the craziest thing it's not
terrible the phone actually starts at
$100 but if you're an Amazon Prime
member you can get a $50 version that
places ads on your lockscreen
it's certainly no new iPhone or Samsung
Galaxy or even a $350 Nexus 5x but if
you just need the basics for web
browsing social media and email this
might fit the bill terrible pun intended
let's start with the good stuff
including the fact that this thing feels
more like a hundred and fifty bucks than
50 bucks it has a metal frame with
curved edges and it's got a big 720p
5-inch screen no one isn't quite as good
as the Moto G's 1080p screen but again
$50 scrolling through Facebook and web
browsing is smooth enough playing
pokemon go however please don't crash I
just want to get the rare Pokemon I
would suggest the $60 version with two
gigabytes of RAM battery life is also
surprisingly good I've had no problems
getting through a full day so how did
they get to $50 with a few not so bad
trade-offs
the base model only has 8 gigabytes of
storage though you can pop in a micro SD
card then there are those ads on the
lockscreen
some will just swipe them away and move
on others like me will be annoyed by the
pocket billboard typing software that
would have come in handy
25 years ago then there's the bad stuff
I mean really bad the 8 megapixel camera
takes photos that remind me of ones I
took 15 years ago with the first digital
cameras if you want better shots you'll
have to pay more even the $200 Huawei
takes better photos and that's the thing
it really comes down to what you need
and what you can spend six hundred and
fifty dollars will buy you the very best
flagship phone
the Samsung Galaxy s7 with a superb
screen camera and speedy performance
dropping down to a mid tier $400 phone
like the Nexus 5 or one plus three is
the sweet spot with 1080p screens good
cameras and fingerprint sensors under
$200 you'll give up some of that speed
and camera performance but still get a
big 1080p screen under $100 you'll get
this blue r1 HD which requires loads of
compromises but just this single bill
awesome